a mother warthog leads her piglets out
of the den for the very first time as
they move away from the den two or more
mothers often sisters themselves will
band together it's an extended family
and it means more security for the young
cousins and more fun too
first some rivalries must be sorted out
with a little bumping and pushing and
then it's playtime one warthog is a bit
bolder and bouncier than the rest to
follow in his wake
but there's method in this apparent
madness
one day their lives will depend on their
speed a little strenuous exercise
deserves a good long drink up pick me up
of piglets Mother's Milk
up a shady marula tree a leopard is on
the lookout for prey as the heat of the
day builds the warthogs head down to the
water hole for a real treat a good walk
but they're not the only ones going that
way
the mother warthog is alert but she
hasn't yet picked up the threat the
water feels great
the youngsters including the bold and
bouncy one are caught up in their
discoveries they're finding out how
useful the mud can be for those
hard-to-reach spots
a few feet more and she'll be in range
the predator must kill to survive the
prey must escape tails at full mast the
little warthog and his siblings stay
close together they have just been given
their first lesson in the virtues of
speed it won't be their last